I realized I've been forgetting to click
the buttons this whole time and we have
to click
the Trombly and I play flounder my name
is
Sebastian I'm Jonah Howard King I play
Prince Eric one of them and they play
King Triton I am Haley and I play Ariel
I'm Melissa McCarthy
we are here
to find out which character we all
really are
[Music]
first thing first which organelle The
Little Mermaid character would you trust
most with a secret Ariel flounder
Scuttle princess Eric Trident or
Sebastian not Sebastian for sure
that's obvious I would say none of them
they like to talk a lot I would say
Ariel Ariel thank you yes this entire
Rose offended yeah I'm gonna tell
Scuttle because I feel like he'd tell
the secret but he would tell it wrong
that's really good news
I
might be a little biased but I'm gonna
choose flounder he seems very loyal I
would choose flounder I think because he
loves Ariel and the family so much and I
feel like he's so loyal and he would
really try his hardest to hold him the
secret first of all I want to say I'm
not even an option
you're right like me I'm not even an
option
um am I still in the film I would say
Triton and here's why because I think I
would be so low on his uh list of things
to do that he probably wouldn't really
listen to me he'd just be like just put
her back on her inner Lair I'm choosing
Prince Eric for the same reason he cares
so much about Harry I always care about
my he didn't even hear it you didn't
choose I know
uh-oh next pick the gadget or Gizmo that
calls to you a fork a cup a pencil a
pipe a compact mirror or a big old Shell
I'm gonna have to go with a big old
Shell it's so cool and it makes a
beautiful sound so I would go with that
one yeah
it's your thing exactly
I would say a compact mirror less for me
but my character is a full narcissist
and possibly I am too I don't know I'm
doing a fork because it is the most my
most used of any of these yeah it's
unfunctional yeah I'm going for a pipe
because I feel like it would make me
seem distinguished or sophisticated a
cup a cup a cup is great
we love I'll do a pencil because you can
I feel like you could do a lot with a
pencil oh that's sweet you're going out
to karaoke with friends which iconic
Disney villain tune do you see be
prepared The Lion King mother knows best
Tangled friends on the other side the
princess and the Frog Gaston Beauty and
the Beast Cruella Deville 101 Dalmatians
or Poor Unfortunate Souls The Little
Mermaid
oh well I mean I shouldn't pick my own
although it's my favorite mother knows
best Tangled it's a big on the way to
school song I would say Poor Unfortunate
Souls because you just kill it and I
think everyone is gonna just be like wow
what the heck she's amazing when they
hear her virgin because she is amazing I
just hand you twenty dollars
I'm gonna do friends on the other side I
think that one's really cool I love that
movie a lot and like that whole thing
with the the giant masks I think was
such a cool sequence out of solidarity
for you Melissa more Unfortunate Souls
you know because you know because you
aren't even in the option in the other
one
[Laughter]
did you think poor unfortunately the
right choice I think I have a better
chance of being able to do Cruella
Deville so that's what happens I'm gonna
do be prepared because scar is one of
the best Disney villains he is he's a
scary song though it is a frightening
that's a frightening actually it's very
frightening yeah all that energy yeah
I'll join the be prepared one it suits
me better yeah
it's a duet actually
which Disney sidekick or Sidekicks would
you most like to befriend in real life
Olaf the genie Pua Mushu Baymax and
Timon and Puma I would have to go with
the Genie or actually maybe Baymax just
because like yeah if you get hurt like
you could actually not I take it back
Genie
all of these are pariahs you know what I
mean these all of these slow down your
mission give you bad advice you have to
like make multiple stops probably Genie
yeah that's so fun yeah I have a theme
for a laugh me too oh love the only
issue is that you would yeah it might
just melt I would just live with them in
a freezer it's fine he makes terrible
decisions but it doesn't matter I just
love them I agree with Olaf it's so
sweet and funny what's up
but it really was I'm gonna what's the
one word you hope your loved one uses to
describe you when you are not around
loyal compassionate funny honest
intelligent creative I will go with
compassionate because honest is like you
know that's code word for for you know
what I mean
it's like someone with no filter
yeah honest all of them
compassionate or all of them I'm gonna
predom this and say all of them why not
come on we are actors
I'm kind of loaded you're right like
other than compassion I feel like if
you're intelligent it's like you're
pretentious
I'm going compassionate as well loyal is
good but just to be different I'll pick
creative and I realize I've been
forgetting to click the buttons this
whole time and we have to click yeah I
haven't been clicking if you were a mer
person what color would you want your
tail to be the options are pink red
purple green blue silver I think silver
would be so cool correct yeah I'm gonna
choose purple though if you had red red
hair as well oh yeah I like these yeah
so if I go with a mermaid tail I mean
yeah yeah Dopey don't try to hide it so
far just answer whatever you answer I'm
like yeah me too I'm here you've all you
haven't been clicking yeah I think I
would say red I agree with Jonah I think
red with red hair would be good
I would like a rainbow option but it's
not here so I did say pink as well which
Disney location would you most like to
visit on vacation
Pride Rock from The Lion King Tiana's
restaurant from The Princess and the
Frog BEAST's Castle from Beauty and the
Beast the Sultan's Palace from Aladdin
the magical family house from Encanto
these are so hard because I'm like not
trying to go through that but like I'm
not trying to go to the Beauty and the
Beast Castle unless they can talk to you
can they talk to you there and how long
are you trapped wouldn't that be fun I
don't know what's kind of scary his wing
was scary maybe he like renovated since
he changed I don't do ice palaces I
would have to say Tiana's restaurant I'm
sorry to make some good food Pride Rock
I think for the views yeah I think I
agree um Pride Rock is good because also
then you'd see like a bunch of wildlife
yeah right you know see all the lions
and zebras and stuff maybe even a
stampede
I wouldn't be the maligal family so I
understand what they're talking about
yeah
hey
what I'm talking about dude what
I'm gonna go to dinner
I'm a kind soul with a pure heart oh
thanks you're a problem solver who's
always available to lend a hand to a
friend in trouble and do everything in
your power to cheer people up when
they're down is that true that's so
so it may not be in your name the way it
is for some other princesses but you are
certainly Charming
[Applause]
at your core you're a princess with
heart for adventure you're kind friendly
and optimistic you love going to new
places and trying new things after all
you just want to be where the and it
says read more people people
have a princess with a heart for
adventure you really are that's how I
describe you I got you Ursula and it
says you're cool calm and calculating in
the best way you're also probably pretty
good at multitasking because of all
those arms you know yeah but I have two
arms though some scuttled during the
life of the party definitely the fun
friend the type of friend who everyone
else asks this about is your name coming
to this otherwise I'm not going
people love your energy and silliness
you make every room you are in a little
more interesting
I asked that before I came here it's
like is Javier gonna be there
and then you rip your sleeves off yeah
so much BuzzFeed we had so much fun
finding out which characters we actually
are and you can see the little mermaid
in theaters May 26th and you have to
click the button yeah these are the
things we've learned
[Music]
foreign